[Music]
we've all seen it before
a magician pulling a rabbit from a hat
it's been featured everywhere from
late-night shows like The Tonight Show
Starring Jimmy Fallon to the big screen
so how did these fluffy household pets
become so closely tied to magic as it
turns out
rabbits are practically made for the
stage and there's a bizarre history
behind the trick let's start with the
logical reasons first there are simply
more of them than any other species
rabbits undergo something called
postpartum estrus no that's not some
sort of Harry Potter spell it means that
they can conceive more babies
immediately after giving birth they have
a unique ability to conceive up to seven
young four to five times a year now
that's a lot of bunnies second their
color helps them stand out as many
old-school magicians have explained the
white fur of rabbits contrasts perfectly
with their black suits and hats it also
helps the animals stand out against a
typical red curtain another image
commonly associated with magic next
let's talk about the body of the bunny
rabbits are known to be compressible
animals meaning they look larger than
they really are
think about it when you see the long
ears the long legs and the long feet
come out of a box or top hat it seems
unbelievable
that's because if you were to stretch
out a rabbit from its toe to the tip of
its ear it would be significantly longer
than if it was just sitting it's a
perfect pet optical illusion now the
real question is who started this combo
of rabbits and magic that would be Mary
talked who successfully pulled off quite
possibly the world's most intense hoax
to date back in 18th century England she
was struggling to make ends meet Mary
developed an unhealthy obsession with
rabbits in obtaining rabbit meat keep in
mind that during this era people
profited off of disfigurement think
circus freak shows like conjoined twins
contortionist and all the other stuff
you saw in the greatest showman what was
the stunt you asked she decided she
would convince the world that she gave
birth to a litter of rabbits in order to
do this
she put animal parts will say under her
skirt and acted out the process of
giving birth I guess in her mind she'd
be making enough money off this stunt to
eat rabbit meat every day for the rest
of her life doctors from around Europe
and visited and left fully believing in
her strange power even the king and
Prince of Wales bought it finally she
was caught sneaking rabbits into her
room and the jig was up but news of this
miracle had already spread far and wide
and her stunt resulted in people
thinking of rabbits as magical animals
people began banning rabbits do and
other harmful treatments allowing the
population to grow now that we covered
that let's move on to how top hats got
involved in all of this when top hats
started becoming popular in the late
1770s magicians picked up on its unique
shape and size allowing objects to be
easily concealed inside they started
borrowing them for shows in the rest is
history
although Louis compt was the first to
attempt the rabbit out of the hat trick
in 1814 it was John Henry Anderson that
made the trick what it is today his
marketing skills came in handy as he
created wooden posters of himself
producing rabbits from hats which drew a
worldwide attention
ever since then more and more magicians
have charted and the rabbit out of a hat
trick has truly become the face of magic
modern-day magicians definitely care
about their little hoppers no one ever
pulls rabbits by their ears that's a
common misconception magicians today
pickup the bunnies like any pet owner
would magicians are still careful to
keep their bunny sidekicks safe so safe
in fact that I even decided to trust in
the process and visit Fantasma magic
where I taught my pet bunny Leah to
disappear you want me to do a little
magic with Leah yes we can definitely
teach us some tricks bye Leah bye-bye
bye-bye I think
uh sorry we are sorry
Fantasma Magican yay
seriously uh awesome what a amazing
beautiful ribbon you use yes yes
as fun as learning magic was I think
it's safe to say Leo is happy to be back
in my arms we'll leave the magic to the
professionals
[Music]